good morning the weekly jobless claims
report just released
885 000 people have filed for first-time
unemployment that is more than was
predicted they were expecting
815 000 which is still a gigantic number
uh here's reaction fox news contributor
and former obama
economic advisor robert wolf screen left
right there
and white house economic recovery task
force member
steve moore steve since you were
involved with this administration let's
start with you that's a that's not a
good number
no it isn't and you know steve it's
heartbreaking because we had the best
recovery going on
in the history of the united states
getting the unemployment rate down
so rapidly very very rapid growth we had
the 33
growth in the third quarter we were
growing at a really rapid pace
uh until about the start of december and
what happened is that all over the
country
these blue state governors from cuomo to
pritzker to
newsome out on the left coast shut down
their their
economies you're seeing the tragedy of
these uh restaurants that are going
bankrupt right now
even though we know that that uh
shutdowns and lockdowns of the economy
have
have almost no impact on the pandemic
and so obviously if you shut down
businesses steve
you're going to see people lose their
jobs it is a tragedy
we should stop the shutdowns obviously
want to stop the spread of the virus but
this is a a strategy that has not worked
and
and many many uh businesses are in
jeopardy of
failing the as you know the 21 club in
uh in new york
is is bankrupt now because of these uh
insane lockdowns
well robert you know the problem with
the lockdowns is if the state
is going to ask somebody to shut down
there's got to you got to be able to pay
the people and that's what the ppp was
all about and you know congress you know
the senate and the house has sat on
have sat on their hands for the last
number of months
waiting to do something it sounds now
like people are actually going to wind
up with the stimulus checks directly
paid to people either 600 or 700 bucks
300 dollars per week in jobless benefits
and
it sounds like a quarter of a trillion
dollars in ppp
funding that's going to help people who
are actually at those restaurants mr
wolfe
yeah so steve first of all you know this
super v-shape recovery that my friend
steve moore talks about has been a
complete hoax
we have 10 million more people i think
we're past that's it
now this goes into your point we have 13
million people that continually
um have been coming every week with new
jobless claims
one in five restaurants small businesses
so it's time for
the cares act 2.0 this 900 plus billion
to be passed
but the way steve's predicting and
saying it's a blue state versus red
state
these 900 000 people that came for
jobless claims for a first time
today trust me those are in the united
states
steve is making this political this is
not political
when we have 13 million more people
unemployed
it's not political this is not the best
recovery ever it's far from it it's one
of the worst ever
and that's why trump in 30 days will not
be in office
because he didn't know how to handle the
pandemic that's just facts
we can cause all this point fingers but
at the end of the day
look how many people have died look at
how many people are unemployed
and it's about time congress is passing
a damn bill
that we've been actually both sides been
proposing for months to just get done
you know and steve um robert makes some
good points about the
the metrics of how many people have you
know
the number of people who have entered
poverty for the first time in their
lives
is is heartbreaking but at the same time
the disconnect
is wall street the stock exchange is
near
all-time highs so it's like look at that
number it's really good in fact if you
look at the
futures right now we're in the green for
today when they open at 9 30
but still there's all this poverty in
the country right now
well look this is a really important
point and robert was just wrong on the
facts robert
i was just in florida two weeks ago
florida is open for business they have
not shut down their businesses
it's new york it's california it's
connecticut
it's new jersey the ten states that have
completely locked down their economies
all have democratic governors and guess
rob what robert
the people who are signing up for
unemployment insurance are in those
states those states that have shut down
their businesses so that's the important
thing
to realize it's just true by the way the
blue states have
current rates that are two and a half
percentage points higher than the states
like georgia
and texas and tennessee and utah why
doesn't the
city of new york start opening up its
businesses so people can go back to work
yeah good point all right robert you got
the final word i mean
let's be clear one it's not accurate
we're losing unemployment throughout the
country the pandemic has hit everyone
throughout the country
and steve knows 40 of hospitality and
leisure employment that's
throughout the entire nation including
florida
okay has been devastated this is not a
blue red state thing
the economy is being hit for all and if
steve's so sure and the president's so
short and you just want to give stimulus
checks to the blue state
people go right ahead because they'll
take it but my guess is people in
georgia
they're glad that a stimulus check is
being passed
well i tell you what uh governor
desantis down in florida said two days
ago
that he would not shut down the
hospitality industry
including the restaurant so let's see
what happens but they are uh
not in florida all right 40 of lost jobs
all right uh robert you're right about
that but the businesses are open
uh robert right there and stephen we
thank you very much